I've been a member since 1986 nearly 40
years it's just a beautiful building
very nice staff lovely place
my name is Pisa Lee I am 79 80 later
this year I'm won the British Chess
Championship when I was 21 and I played
in the England team for about 10 years
my name is
eight my ratings around 1800 and I won
the world's underwright girls rapid and
Blitz championships ladies are allowed
in now but they used not to be here
until 20 years ago would you like to see
a bit of the club in theory no one under
14s would go in the club
[Music]
so I've always been into problem solving
everything I do I do I play bridge as
well I do crosswords I do number games
I'm a medical statistician I call myself
a problem solver
I started liking the pieces and I wanted
to take them and keep them so then my
dad said I could play chess instead
when I gave up when I was about 31 to I
was 2 3 90 and I've only played one
greater games since then what did you
say you're rating 1900s 1800 18
even if you're not not not ahead of me
yet you'll be ahead of me in two or
three years time
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
well she played she played a lot of very
sensible moves did you think you were
winning at one stage maybe slightly
better slightly maybe slightly better
yeah you probably were
[Music]
do you know about Nobel prizes
over 50 members of the afternoon have
won Nobel prizes Bertram Russell Winston
Churchill gradual Kipling have you heard
of well you're too young you don't know
all these people
[Music]
tactically I'm quite I'm still quite
strong I can still give me a position in
the paper white to play and win the
first move I think of is usually the
answer I think I'm quite good at the
hurricane games but I'm not sure about
my weakness this is the more I think the
most expensive library in the world
after British museum
[Music]
this is the Darwin chair have you heard
of Charles Darwin
they play between each other chess can I
go up the stairs or am I not allowed do
you want to go up the stairs I've never
been up the stairs let's go up the
stairs this is high
what's the best thing over here it's an
old thing for parcel posts so if you
have to send a parcel the way you put
the parcel in one and you put the
weights in the other and when it
balances you know the parcel weighs four
pounds or um so many grams
[Music]
I think the optimum age for playing my
first chest will probably be when I'm
somewhere around a teenager mid-30s is
probably the best the people reach their
reach their strongest and um
so at age 79 I'm probably a bit past it
[Music]
it's interesting
all right
foreign
[Music]
yeah
yeah is it there just in time thank you
that little girl is eight and she's the
strongest chess player of either sex in
the world in the world of her age so
she's just beaten me and I'm an
ex-british champion
on the school day I would probably take
an hour in the morning for chess and
then I I would come back from school at
around four and then I think I would do
chess again up till like
eight nine stuff and then I would go to
bed
typical day for me get up have breakfast
go out stagger out with my broken leg to
the um to the paper shop to get the
papers meet up with people for lunch or
dinner and in the evening I often play
bridge matches
well my my father taught me when I was
about eight or nine and I I read all the
all the chess books in the Chelsea
Public Library and I got very interested
one of my dad's friends was throwing
away some stuff during covert and then
inside there there was a chessboard and
I was curious about the pieces so then I
I watched videos on YouTube and chess
kid and I started learning
I'm not thinking I'm going to suddenly
improve and be back in the England team
no I just do it for enjoyment
um
women's world champion as well
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
played extremely well very very solidly
didn't he miss didn't make mistakes and
made good positional moves all the time
the last time I was wiped out by a woman
was by Nona gaprin dashville in 1966.
she beat me
two two
nice yeah I'm retiring
[Music]